all right matt cohen joins us now hey
welcome back to the jungle man yeah i'm
glad to be back i mean it's i survived
the jungle that is disneyland for the
world premiere
of jungle cruise star dwayne johnson and
emily blunt that's where i got the goods
on dwayne returning to the wwe sort of
what can we look forward to seeing you
back in the wwe is there is there
anything you can tease about that for us
there's nothing
yeah i mean me and him big tactics
our money's on emily but we're not the
only ones who love to see the rocket
back in the ring
for him to be gracious enough to return
to wwe
its own global entertainment phenomenon
that is great for wwe
and i think it is great for the rock as
a fan of wwe i really hope he returns
[Music]
dwayne and emily cruised in on the ride
that inspired the movie for saturday
night's star-studded premiere
who are we with tonight hi guys my
wife's hiding over here hi my name is
ava
hi my name is this is her first premiere
we should take a big selfie all right
here we go
one two three
jungle cruise hits theaters in disney
plus with premiere access
this friday you can expect lots of fun
smack talk between its stars
i don't got it no no no no no look at
this just leave me alone that was a
disaster it didn't go the way i planned
it's time were you up doing your
push-ups what time um i don't sleep
so i was already out yes that's why you
look rough anyway
keep going
[Music]
you